[Music]
a trophy belladonna will kill you
detura will put you to sleep forever
i can item will kill you
laurel will produce cyanide and kill you
every plant here in the poison garden is
poisonous and has the ability to kill
you
[Music]
my name is trevor jones and i'm the head
gardener of anik garden this plant is
giant hogweed it will get up to around
about eight foot high it's phototoxic so
will burn your skin and give you
blisters for up to seven years
this garden is set in the wall garden of
the old castle in northumberland uk
we'd have around about 95 plants
and we're adding to the collection all
the time
this plant is akinatum or monkshood
wonderful blue flowers but the whole of
the plant is poisonous the berries
crushed up and fed to you will kill you
the leaves themselves will kill you also
as will the root and the stem we have to
obviously maintain the garden so we have
to tend the plants and when we do that
we have to be very careful of the way we
operate so we have to cover some of our
skin when we deal with particularly
dangerous plants
this plant is lol it produces cyanide
and we all know what that'll do to you
so it's the brainchild of the duchess
dutchess of northumberland so rather
than having a herb garden she decided to
create more interest and have a poison
garden they're very very common plants
in fact a lot of them are what we call
cottage garden plants and they're grown
in many people's gardens but people
don't know how harmful they actually are
[Music]
this is a trope of belladonna four
berries are enough to kill a child
people are intrigued by poisonous plants
and often very worried when they come
out because many of them will be growing
these plants at home
they don't realize the powerful impact
plants can have on us as humans
is it something that you find
fascinating definitely why
it's a good way to get rid of your life
[Music]
how'd you know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
until about 1902 legal food
preservatives included chemicals like
formaldehyde borax and copper sulfate
that is until one guy organized a poison
supper club to stop it and became the
father of the fda
okay here's the story
in order to keep food looking fresh food
manufacturers used a slew of chemicals
copper sulfate a common pesticide made
canned peas bright green
borax and formaldehyde were packed with
meat to make it appear fresher
at this time in our history there were
no true food regulations you didn't need
to label your ingredients there was no
safety testing no monitoring
cue dr harvey w wiley a chemist with the
crazy idea that these chemicals had no
place in our food
he started some hygienic lab trials
where he could officially test the
effects of these poisons on the body
it was easy to get the chemicals
but he needed the bodies
and that's where the poison squad came
in
the first 12 members of the poison squad
were volunteers from the department of
agriculture and they volunteered to eat
his poison food for six months so he
could track the effects it had on them
each day the menus would change and
wiley's volunteers never knew which
poison they were consuming
[Music]
a dinner at the poison supper club might
look like this
applesauce soup turkey canned string
beef sweet potato white potato chipped
beef bread and butter coffee rice
pudding and a little borax
[Music]
throughout the trials wiley noted signs
of acute poisoning including upset
stomachs nausea diarrhea vomiting kidney
damage you know things that happen when
you get poisoned and this did not stay
hidden the press caught on and in 1906
the first food regulations were passed
this ultimately led to the creation of
the fda so thanks dr wily our food is so
much better without all that borax
[Music]
in a remote part of japan lives a highly
toxic plant called the cycad and believe
it or not people consume it regularly
beloved and cherished by the native
people of amami oshima eating the plant
in its raw form could kill you
[Music]
amami oshima is home to hundreds of
types of toxic plants the cycad has been
a staple crop on the island for
generations because it is so poisonous
locals take the necessary steps to make
the plants safe for human consumption
[Music]
sensing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
through the process of fermentation and
drying the poison is extracted from the
plant
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a
[Music]
[Music]
in movies like kerry blood comes by the
buckets
perfecting that red gooey mess took a
long time and several different recipes
this is the story of how fake movie
blood is made
[Music]
back before film and tv a simple red
handkerchief on stage symbolized blood
but it was kind of boring
so some theaters upped the ante by
boiling a bug known for its red pigment
they used the cochineal bug because it
creates red dye
when black and white movies came along
pigment didn't matter so hollywood
simplified things by using chocolate
syrup
then in the 1930s when black and white
movies turned to color hollywood needed
a new blood trick enter john tynegate a
retired pharmacist living in england he
concocted the most realistic looking
blood yet called kensington gore using a
combination of mostly golden syrup food
coloring corn flour and water
the most famous of the blood recipes
though comes from a man named dick smith
he came up with something on par with a
julia child recipe
the catch his recipe was poisonous one
ingredient kodak photo flow is deadly
when consumed
so people started replacing the poison
with creamer and other items that won't
kill you
today a lot of the fake blood you see on
screen is computer generated but if you
want to be legit it should be poison or
bugs
you